in 1989 Japan's Shinkansen bullet train
had a problem it was fast really fast
like pushing a hundred and seventy miles
per hour fast but every time it exited a
tunnel it was loud the noise was coming
from a variety of sources but whenever a
train sped into a tunnel it pushed waves
of atmospheric pressure through the
other end the air exited tunnels with a
sonic boom that could be heard 400
meters away in dense residential areas
that was a huge problem so an
engineering team was brought in to
design a quieter faster and more
efficient train and they had one secret
weapon aging nakatsu the general manager
of the technical development department
was a birdwatcher different components
of the redesign bullet train were based
on different birds
owls inspired the pantograph that's the
rig that connects the train to the
electric wires above nakatsu modeled the
redesign after their feathers reducing
noise by using the same serrations and
curvature that allow them to silently
swoop down to catch prey the Adelie
penguin whose smooth body allows it to
swim and slide effortlessly inspired the
pantograph supporting shaft redesigned
for lower wind resistance and perhaps
most notable of all was the Kingfisher
[Music]
the Kingfisher is a bird that dives into
water to catch its prey the unique shape
of its beak allows it to do that while
barely making a splash nakatsu took that
shape to the design table the team shot
bullets shaped like different train nose
models down a pipe to measure pressure
waves and drop them into water to
measure the splash size the quietest
nose design was the one modeled most
closely after the kingfishers beak when
the redesign debuted in 1997 it was 10%
faster used 15% less electricity and
stayed under the 70 decibel noise limit
in residential areas and it did all that
with the wings of an owl the belly of a
penguin and the nose of a Kingfisher
there's a name for design like this it's
called biomimicry the people who design
our world usually never take a biology
class believe it or not so they're
they're novices in how the world works
that's Janine Benyus back in 1997 she
wrote the book that coined the term
biomimicry it told the story of the
innovations and computing energy and
health that were inspired by structures
in the natural world stick like a gecko
compute like a cell even run a business
like a redwood forest Benyus has since
worked as a consultant for various
companies trying to get them to
understand how to take design ideas from
nature that might mean studying prairie
dog burrows to build better air
ventilation systems mimicking sharkskin
to create bacteria resistant plastic
surfaces for hospitals or arranging wind
turbines in the same drag-reducing
pattern at schools of fish swimming
designers get inspiration from a lot of
different places but Benyus thinks many
of them could benefit from looking more
at the natural world so there's a lot of
sort of looking at what other people
have done and what they do is they look
at all the others and they get ideas
they get they literally do you know a
lot of a lot of designers have lots of
magazines that they look through they
tear those out
the Hmong inspiration boards but they're
looking at other human technologies her
idea was simple designers should get in
the habit of bringing a biologist to the
table and let them help solve problems
by mimicking nature and there are three
main ways they can do that you know you
can mimic its form or its shape you
might create a paint for a building that
when it dries it's got the same
structure as self-cleaning leaves
lotus leaves are notoriously great they
let rainwater clean the leaf because
because they have these bumps and that
rainwater balls up on the bumps and then
it pearls away the dirt so that Lotus
effect is physical and you can you can
create a physical structure on the
outside of any product imagine that on
the outside of your car rainwater would
clean your car
so that's mimicking form but there's
also mimicking process the processes in
the natural world it might even be you
know how you mimic how ants communicate
in order to efficiently find sources of
food or new new places to live and those
processes that self-organization has
been mimicked in software you know in
things like or you know autonomous cars
and how they're gonna move in flocks
through the city by talking to one
another
that's mimicking nature's process and
then you jump up to the level of
mimicking whole ecosystems right there's
the thing called that's a buzzword right
now that's really hot called the
circular economy which is essentially
you know industry saying you know there
are there's no there should be no such
thing as a byproduct in our
manufacturing facility that goes to
landfill it should be used by something
else right and at the end of a product's
life that product should be up cycled
into something else that's being called
the circular economy eco systems do that
really really really well you've got a
log on the forest floor and those
materials move up into the body of the
fungus that eats it those materials move
up into
a mouse and that Mouse material moves up
into a hawk right and if you think about
that is what we'd like to do with local
materials being up cycled constantly in
our cities for instance those ecosystem
lessons are really big for us and that's
the end goal for biomimetic design
making products systems and cities
functionally indistinguishable from the
natural world life has been around on
earth for 3.8 billion years and what
designers are starting to realize is
that that is a lot of research and
development time the people who design
our world have a lot to learn from the
natural world all they have to do is
take a look thank you so much for
watching this is one of a series of
videos that we're doing in collaboration
with 99% invisible they are a podcast
that does stories all about design we
loved working with them you should
definitely check them out at 99 peon org
or on any podcast app
[Music]
you